[Music]
we're so excited to start a new chapter
massive tent bouquets of flowers
portable generators britney's backyard
was buzzing with prep for her i do's but
her fiance sam was playing it cool how's
the waiting preparation going
great man it's going to be one day
nice
[Music]
until the next day
all eyes on us the pre-party kicked off
yesterday that sam behind the wheel of a
white rolls royce britney's in the back
seat with her agent i'm really excited
there's stores on the ceiling a source
tells e.t brittany and sam have felt
like true partners for a long time and
can't wait to officially be husband and
wife the guest list well we're told it's
a small ceremony britney's brother brian
spears will reportedly be there but keep
in mind that brittany's been at odds
with most of her family since her
conservatorship battle our source says
britney's mom lynne her dad jamie and
her little sister jamie lynn are not
invited also britney's two sons won't be
there kevin federline's powerhouse
attorney mark vincent kaplan tells e.t
kevin and the boys are happy for
brittany and wish her and sam all the
best going forward as for brittany's
wedding dress she revealed last year
that donatella versace had already
started working on it didn't bridges
post she's designing the wedding gown oh
yes it's the happiest time of our lives
and we're just enjoying it we are all
super excited about this britney spears
wedding what can you tell us i want to
see brittany because i always care about
her i find her in great spirits
fantastic she's special she's something
she's a good heart
sam also shared this after party tidbit
i think i'm going to put together a real
cool dance and this is wild the singer
has a surprising ally in her quest to
keep the ceremony private joe biden
the president in l.a resulting in tight
restrictions today on paparazzi and
helicopters that might normally fly
overhead
so how does britney's third wedding
compare with her previous i do's
[Music]
she and kevin federline got married at a
friend's house the planning just 10 days
and she surprised us all walking down
the aisle in vegas with high school
sweetheart jason alexander that lasted
just 55 hours and was later annulled
honestly i really wanted to see what it
was like to be married
maybe that sounds silly but in in that
moment i was just um i was with a friend
and i that i love dearly and
i wanted to do something wild and crazy
today's wedding comes nearly four weeks
after britney revealed she had a
miscarriage and nearly nine months after
she and sam announced their engagement
what kind of wedding do you want to have
what's your dream day you know it's up
to her she's wearing the pants now
finally right yes